Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for a 20 second episode!
Moco-chan, 22!
One two for me, one two for you.
No two for the ruffians.
I am already very... Moisturized!
Moisturized!
Yes!
Great start!
Revenge!
Well, Ruffians!
I think I saw a couple Ruffians talking about that maybe this was their first time today, so let us explain what FUWAMOCO Morning is all about!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO.
Today is Wednesday and it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Ruffians, if you could do us a favor and maybe tweet some of your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING.
That would make us really happy.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
And to start your day off, has another Ruffian seen Pero around?
I think so.
Where is he this time?
Pero!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Not again.
It looks like Pero was spotted somewhere very, very familiar again.
Right, Moco-chan?
Do you know where this is?
No.
Moco-chan, no don't you.
No, I don't.
Ruffians, you know, right?
Moco-chan.
I've never seen this place in my life.
Uh-uh.
Wow.
You know, Ruffians, we originally went to this place.
To, yeah.
To the backrooms.
We went to the backrooms a few weeks ago after Pero was spotted there, but as you know, it didn't really work out as we had planned.
Yeah.
Maybe this is, you know, Pero's way of making a game out of things, you know?
It's not a game, though.
To me, it's just mean.
It's probably so that, you know, we become stronger guard dogs, right?
I don't know.
This time, you know, we're going to be guided around by some of the best of the best, by Fubuki-senpai!
Yay!
You know, so not only can we try to want some more rescue Pero, but we gotta be extra brave, right Moco-chan?
That way, Fubuki-senpai's impressed!
I don't think Hubuki-senpai is going to be impressed, but we can do our best, okay?
At least maybe the Ruffians will be impressed.
Ruffians!
Will you be impressed even if Hubuki-senpai isn't?
You have to say yes.
Yes?
No.
You have to say yes.
I saw no.
Moco-chan, understand?
This time, no complaining about being in pain or losing the feeling in your limbs.
Okay?
I can't promise that.
No, that's just going to be embarrassing otherwise.
Fubuki-senpai's gonna think FUWAMOCO's weird.
I think Fubuki-senpai will think that no matter what.
BAU BAU!
Please, ruffians, let us know if you see Pero around again, okay?
Make sure you get a really good shot of him.
Also, don't forget to use the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians!
There's some really good, good, good news!
Yeah!
Oh, we talked about it before.
Maybe it's unexpected, but... Actually, we saw Papa Puppy very, very briefly.
Do you remember when we complained to you about how many FUWAMOCO it takes to replace a lightbulb?
We still had one lightbulb that wasn't really working anymore.
Yeah.
So, you know we told Papa Puppy, uh, and, uh, because, you know, especially for me, the lightbulb was important.
It kind of made things a little bit dangerous since it wasn't working anymore.
It was in the kitchen, you know?
Yeah, so I was kind of chopping things up in the dark.
I'm okay.
I didn't hurt myself yet.
No accidents.
Yeah.
Not like me.
So imagine it's a Papa Puppy and you know what?
You know what, Ruffians?
Papa Puppy!
He just flicked the light and it was blinking again!
I fixed it.
We were like that in the dark for so long.
We're glad it was such a simple fix, but... It's a bit embarrassing too, you know?
Why?
It didn't even need anything.
Right?
I was chopping things up in the dark for no reason.
Why is it like that?
Maybe this is just part of Papa Puppy's duty, right?
And that was it.
Everything is good.
Unfortunately, the good news ends there.
Because...
Guardic Four Ruffians.
Do you know what happened in Guardic Four?
Guardic Four... Can you guess?
It was a misunderstanding.
A misunderstanding.
Again!
Again, Ruffians!
We did our best, but maybe... Maybe it wasn't good enough this time.
Doing Guarded Floor with Advent.
Moco-chan!
Moco-chan here.
You made the mistake of implying that...
Biboo has given, uh, can give birth to moai statues.
Uh, and then, uh, uh, mistakenly, of course, Bijou then requested artists to get creative, uh, only to then realize her mistake.
Yeah, I didn't mean anything.
Yeah, it's just all a big misunderstanding!
Yeah, okay!
Yeah, we thought, you know, that, uh, we would be okay this time, you know?
I have confidence.
But...
But we want you to understand one thing, Ruffians.
Moco-chan, I'm innocent.
I'm just an innocent puppy.
And Biboo... Biboo doesn't want everyone thinking about her giving birth to Moai statues.
Okay?
Nope.
Understood?
It's cancelled, okay?
I didn't mean to make anyone think about that sort of thing ever.
You know it.
It just wouldn't happen.
I know.
In fact, it's your fault for even thinking about it, okay?
It's not mine.
Got it?
I agree.
Yeah.
Ruffians, don't even think it.
That thought, yeah.
Canceled.
You know it.
It was just sort of implied.
It wasn't me that made it happen, okay?
It was you.
Yeah.
Got it.
Misunderstanding?
Yeah.
I didn't type anything.
No.
Yeah.
Okay.
Understood.
BAU BAU.
Yeah.
Okay, forget about that.
I... Actually...
A misunderstanding and apology!
I know I thought we could do better, but... Ruffians... You know... Okay, well this is good then.
This is good.
That means that I really have to make an apology for this one then.
It's a good thing you're doing this.
Doing a stream of Cookie and Cream yesterday.
Ruffians, you might know, I got a bit heated.
Just a bit.
Just a bit, right.
The game was really tricky!
I didn't get heated at all.
It wasn't my fault, you know, but I think I need to apologize for this one.
Within my anger and my rage at the game, I said something that I shouldn't have.
And I think I shocked not only a number of ruffians, but also Moco-chan too, right?
You did.
I was very surprised, very disappointed.
By accident, I might have...
I have said the D word.
I called the boss a dude.
I'm so sorry!
Ruffians, will you forgive me?
Will you forgive her, dude?
Moco-chan, we're gonna have to apologize for you too.
Continue.
Ruffians, you don't think any differently of me now, right?
Your image hasn't been solid or anything, right?
Not forever and ever, right?
You know, it's just that he was moving so slowly and we didn't have much time left.
It was his fault, okay?
Yeah, I know.
So, I really wanted him to hurry up and that's what I might have shouted, Hurry up, dude!
Yeah.
It makes sense.
It was his fault, okay?
I'm sorry, Ruffians!
Next time, I'll make sure to call him Mr. instead, okay?
Yeah, Mr. Mr. Boss.
Mr., if you could, uh, please, please move on.
A little more spryly!
Yeah!
Mr.!
That's what I'll say to him, okay?
Okay.
Sorry again, Ruffians.
Apology accepted.
Not Mr. It's okay.
Okay.
Accepted.
Thank goodness.
The ruffians are kind.
Very accepting of Fuwawa's flaws.
Please don't think any different of me, okay?
BAU BAU!
Next we actually have a special surprise.
What is it, Moco-chan?
We noticed a surprise today on Twitter!
Ruffians, did you see it?
We saw that Parkour-sensei drew a very special picture of Moco-chan!
But this isn't just Moco-chan.
It's Nice Witch Mococo!
How did you know it?
Why?
It's so cute!
Many times she's Moco-chan.
How did you... She's a magical girl.
Like Koubeki-chan!
Right, right!
Moco-chan, what would your magical spell be?
Ruffians!
Moco Moco Fuwa Fuwa Violence!
With that... I don't know.
I'm gonna protect your smile whether you like it or not!
That's one Moco-chan like, I think.
That's Moco-chan like, what is it?
I'm gonna switch.
Moco-chan.
Thank you!
Sneeze magic.
That's not that reliable though, is it?
A beam.
Sneeze beam.
Sneeze cannon.
Hanakara beam.
You know, one of these days we really need to sing I Know Medicine.
Right?
Okay, right!
Hopefully we can someday soon!
Thank you, Paco-sensei!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
That's a wonderful surprise, right Moco-chan?
Right!
Please charge rifle.
Do magical girls have rifles?
Depends on the magical girl, I guess.
What?
I did... I did want to say something.
Something?
You know... I said that I wouldn't do it every week.
But... I felt like you called for it, okay?
So you...
Ruffians!
Hi!
Listen up!
Okay, are you listening?
Are you listening?
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And this time, you're gonna hear from me, Mococo!
You know it.
You're here!
And I know you're a bit sleepy, but you're doing it!
Even though it's rough, you got going for a new day!
And you know that's already half the battle!
No matter how much gets piled onto you, you continue through and you're able to keep going!
You know.
Why are you so amazing?
Even if things don't get going your way, you get back up and do your best.
And you know what that means?
That means you're unstoppable!
Okay.
So, for a moment, let's just stop and take a deep breath together, okay?
Breathe with me.
3... 2... 1...
You can do it!
Hopefully I got the sleepy out of you now.
You got this today!
And you know what?
We'll get a good sleep later and properly recharge your batteries, so don't worry!
Make sure you remember.
I believe in you!
Fuwawa believes in you!
Pero probably believes in you, or he should at least.
We'll make it through together!
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
I believe in you ruffians.
Hopefully Pero does too though.
Hopefully.
I don't know though, I can't speak for him.
I'm gonna believe in Pero that hopefully believes in you.
Moco-chan!
Should we go and see who's the Doggie of the Day today?
It is... It's Chame!
What are you doing there, Chame?
Did you fall asleep?
Very comfy.
It seems like Chame fell asleep between the sliding doors.
But don't worry, Ruffians.
That's pretty normal for him from the sounds of things.
Maybe he just worked really hard.
He really barked up a storm.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I think it's more that Chame's just chilly.
It's really cute though!
Ruffians, do you ever feel like this?
Or you just fall asleep in between the door?
Just like that.
Sometimes you just can't help it.
Sometimes, you know.
But sometimes you should be careful, you know?
It's important to be careful.
Safety.
I just remember the time that I kind of closed my tail in the door.
It was the worst.
I'm better than that.
Chame, please be maybe a little bit more mindful, okay?
Yeah, no injuries.
All safety.
Moco-chan, how does Chame BAU BAU?
I think he's a light.
Cute and light BAU BAU.
Light?
But sort of, I don't know, maybe a bit impatient.
Impatient?
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I think that's exactly it!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Chame!
Chame's a silly best friend.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Is there a Ruffian that went on a walk?
Ruffians, you've been going out for a walk, right?
Today we have... De-den!
An Apple Orchard!
That's so sweet that you went on a walk around an Apple Orchard with your friends.
That's definitely sweet because of all the apples, too.
Nice.
Could you eat them from the trees?
I wonder.
Is that allowed anymore?
Is that gonna be yummy though?
Why not?
Ruffians, have you done this too before?
It looks like this Ruffian picked Honeycrisp Apples.
Are you going to make anything with them?
Like pies?
Or applesauce?
I want to make a pie with them!
It's really fun picking fresh berries, right Moco-chan?
I like that a lot.
It's fun.
Do you remember that one time that we picked the blackberries?
What did we make with them?
We made jam!
Right!
Right?
With wild blackberries that were growing in the Northwest Passage?
Yeah.
And we gave them to Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy?
That was just too much jam.
We hope you enjoy the apples lots and lots.
It was a lot of fun.
I would like to do that too.
It sounds great.
Apple picking with the ruffians.
BAU BAU!
And today we have a question!
Question of the day is... Hi FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
I was wondering if you have any specific rituals or practices that you do to relax when you're nervous before doing something big like an interview or presentation?
Good question.
I think you know after all that guard dog training, we don't really get that nervous anymore.
Maybe.
But when we're feeling a little bit anxious about something, we like to go on a good walk beforehand.
Yeah, a walk is always good.
It brings good energy, good luck, you know, calm you down.
Everything's clear, you know, it helps a lot.
But we also like stretching or other exercise too, but if we really just don't have the time for that, we have another secret.
A secret.
Okay.
Ruffians, can you guess?
Oh.
Non veritas.
We hate each other!
For example, if Moco-chan's really nervous, then I'll rub her back all over.
Rub, rub, rub, rub, rub.
And then I give her a big whack!
It gets all the nerves out, you know it!
It maybe sounds a bit strange, but it does really work.
Sometimes it leaves a bit of a woe, but it's okay.
Moco-chan, you'll do it for me, too.
That might have been what we were doing a bunch before we debuted, right?
Right, right.
Also, in extreme cases, Amoco-chan likes to just lay down flat on the ground and breathe like in a starfish position.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's kind of weird, but... But hopefully, Ruffians, that can help you.
If you ever feel nervous before a big presentation, you just need to find somebody to rub your back and then give it a big... As hard as they can.
It works well, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for your submissions always.
As you know, we're still looking for more Pero Sightings, Doggie of the Day questions, and we want to hear more from you about the kind of walks you're going on too.
So please submit them with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING, okay?
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, what's our next dream?
Our next dream is...
De-den!
We're playing Super Smash Bros.
with Calli-senpai!
The tails are going right against the sides, right?
Ruffians, do you have any good strategies for us?
Or like anything we can do to make Calli-senpai laugh?
Do you want to know a secret?
I thought we were playing Super Smash Bros.
Brawl.
No.
It's Ultimate now.
Oh.
That sounds easier said than done.
I have a feeling it's not us.
Ah.
Not us.
The who.
Let's do our best!
BAU BAU!
Let's take another peek at our schedule.
After our collab with Kaori-senpai, will be our first collab with Fubuki-senpai!
We're super excited of course, but also a bit nervous too.
Please Ruffians, please be there to hold our paws for a lot of different reasons.
After, you know, after we kinda get to the backrooms of Fubuki-senpai, hopefully we find Pero, it's gonna be okay because we're gonna have ton of fun playing Ocarina of Time!
And then, after that, it's another Rock'n'Roll Party!
Yeah, we're gonna be rocking out!
And this time, the theme's been decided.
Huh?
Well, Ruffians, I'm just gonna say, you might not need a time machine to feel like you've gone back in time this time.
That's a lot of time.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today.
Full Assist!
BAU BAU!
Pirate Pete!
Speaker!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!